it was only his third prime minister's
questions and certainly he didn't seem
as on form as as the last one how much
do you think this resignation by Sir
Gavin Williamson has impacted him you're
right so it's his third prime minister's
questions and he had another tough
Wicket to defend if you like and as you
were saying really it looked like he'd
had the stuffing knocked out of him he
just wasn't as on form as combative as I
have seen him um before you know it was
a very difficult position to defend I
mean and kierstama was brutal there the
opener being does the Prime Minister
think how will the victim have felt when
the Prime Minister expressed great
sadness at the resignation he then said
that Gavin Williamson he described him
as a pathetic bully and criticized the
Prime Minister uh for giving him power
and then he pivoted that to the Prime
Minister himself saying that it was a
sign that he was so weak as a boss that
he was worried that the bullies would
turn on him and he hid behind them I
mean it was absolutely damning from
kirstarma towards Rishi sunak and how
did the Prime Minister respond well what
was interesting about this was the tone
he took publicly in the House of Commons
whilst facing MPS was very different to
the tone he took last night when he
accepted Gavin Williamson's resignation
you know number 10 made it clear that
the Prime Minister accepted it he didn't
ask him to resign Gavin Williamson as I
understand it went to see the prime
minister in the early evening of last
night after these new allegations had
surfaced this complaint was made by
formerly to the Parliamentary Watchdog
by this senior former civil servant who
has alleged that Gavin Williamson told
them to Slit their throat and as the
allegations piled up Gavin Williamson
took it upon himself to resign now the
prime minister in the tone of the letter
was pretty warm to Gavin Winston but
that was an about time today and I think
that raises questions about what is the
messaging of Rishi sunak and how he
handles this stuff because in the
comments he said it was absolutely right
he resigned and then he said I obviously
regret putting him into office and then
he said my government is showing the
public that when these things arise I'm
quick to deal with them but he defended
Gavin Williamson for days so so where
does it leave him it's a prime minister
saying on the floor of the house and he
said it repeatedly this is a government
of Integrity professional account and
accountability while at the same time in
the first two weeks of his Premiership
questions about professionalism and
accountability have been raised again
and again again over two appointments he
made I mean he knew that Gavin
Williamson had a live allegation of
bullying against somebody put him back
into cabinet so I think there's a few
things from that number one
is what is number 10 trying to say about
this on the one hand they were warm
about Gavin Williamson last night and
now the prime minister is changing
approaches it's just confusing about the
kind of messaging that they want to get
out number two his question of course it
calls into question his judgment and
it's undermining for him and number
three this is a promise to desperately
trying to reset his government and he
has just got brought down and into
issues around culture of Westminster and
conduct of ministers and people in his
government exactly the sort of problems
that brought Boris Johnson down problems
that Rishi sunak said that he wanted uh
to turn the page on and I think it also
finally Sally speaks to to the divisions
within the conservative party there was
lots of anger about swella Braven being
reappointed there was anger in the party
that Gavin Williamson had been given a
cabinet post when they were widespread
rumors and discussions amongst and he's
about conduct and all of it gives
kirstama these really powerful attack
lines to try and defenestrate Rishi
sunak as a weak prime minister without
legitimacy and every week he just has
another reason to go at him for that and
that was not a comfortable session at
all for the prime minister